[Applause]
hey everybody is Charlie we got a
breakdown the flash 100th episode there
were so many Easter eggs and they paid
off so many ongoing plot lines
confirming big big reverse-flash theory
so we'll do a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment on the video careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet obviously we'll be talking about
very specific stuff so we'll go through
top 10 WTF and comic book Easter eggs so
many comic book Easter eggs starting
with number 10 the intro they decide to
try and capture cicada at his hospital
Nora's reading her book they sort of set
up that sherlock plotline with paying
off what the book is all about what
she's really doing where it's all going
so they did a pretty good job of
presenting you with enough information
to decode how things were going to end
before you get that final end credits
scene with the reverse-flash showing up
the whole idea here is is that Nora
seems to have really convenient ideas
and it various points this season
they've referred to her being a very
clever girl so that's just a recurring
motif in the fact that they mentioned it
so many times in this episode and the
people that mentioned it like
reverse-flash then is Sherlock later in
the episode just confirmed that they
were gonna pay off a big reverse-flash
twist number 9 is a plan so they need to
get a strong alloy Savatage suit zooms
Speed Force siphoning device in the very
specific type of dark matter that was
created when they blew up the particle
accelerator the first time so that just
provides the points at which he goes
back to the past although there was a
fourth time that they went back to at
the very end of the episode where Nora
goes back to watch his parents have a
happy moment I realized based on the
twist at the end of the episode it
presents her as being more sinister
because she's doing something bad
but I think that she's doing it for a
good reason it's just that she's very
naive and she's being manipulated by the
reverse-flash number 8 was elongated
man's appropriate use of back in time by
Huey Lewis from Back to the Future if
you've never heard me talk about it
before Nora is kind of like a Marty
McFly situation they named drop Marty
McFly in the first episode she could
Marty McFly herself out of existence in
a lot of times when describing the tone
of the flash people refer to Back to the
Future so it's kind of a comedy
lighthearted time
style story but really being seed that
they planned it for the future number
seven cisco gives barry an upgraded
version of the flash ring he says he
made some modifications but did not say
what those modifications were we
probably won't find out about that till
after the crossover because on Sunday
the flash episode of else world starts
and we get three episodes then we go
back to normal with episode 10 after the
big break in January it might have
something to do with putting the chin
back on his costume but I expect there
to be a couple surprises with the flash
ring when we come back in episode 10 I'm
not really expecting them to move the
plot forward on the flash TV show that
much during the Elseworlds episodes I
think those will be relatively
self-contained 6 Barry and Nora vs.
Sabbat are so obviously there was a lot
to happen when they were going back in
time to each of these places in the
timestream they get visions like they
always do but typically what happened is
is when they would go back to say season
3 to get the sabotage suit they would
see scenes from season 4 so every time
they went back further in time they
played scenes from the preceding season
so when they went back to see zoom they
played scenes from season 3 and back to
season 1 they played scenes from season
2 and so on and so forth I wasn't really
sure how they were gonna film all these
new scenes of them back in the past
because we knew this avatar would come
back we knew that zoom would come back
we knew that reverse flash would come
back in what they did is is they shot a
little bit of new footage with the
characters and just splice that in with
clips from previous seasons so when
they're doing this here they're
basically doing green screen with Nora
and Barry and they just jam that on top
of a clip from season 3
they didn't completely reshoot all these
scenes but they did a really good job
with the editing I think they spent the
least amount of time in season three
with Savitt R and then with zoom again
so that when they went back to talk to
reverse flash they could spend more time
in those scenes to set up the big payoff
at the end of the episode but number 5
Barry and Nora versus zoom so they shot
a little bit of new footage Harrison
Wells comes in Barry gives him the idea
that will help them find Jesse quick to
sort of keep him from destroying that
device that was the idea that he came up
with during season 2 so it's not like
Barry is making a really big change to
the timeline he's just giving him an
idea that he had already come up with
but that message that Nora wrote at the
end of the episode the timeline is
malleable just lets you know that the
butterfly effect will be worse for some
things than
so like that's why it's okay for Barry
to tell Harrison wells that it was
really fun to see a zoom catch them this
is a new scene so like a lot of this is
old scenes from season two with them
spliced in but they did shoot some new
scenes with zoom so the actor Teddy
Sears did come back to shoot this which
is really cool the funny thing about
that is it also lets you know that he
can sense the Speed Force and other
people the same way that the
reverse-flash did way back in the pilot
episode when they travel back to get the
dark matter like he's getting ready to
press the button but stops for a second
because he kind of senses the Speed
Force nearby the funny thing about them
traveling back and trying to escape zoom
though is is the time rate that's been
chasing them also catches zoom like it
did at the end of season two I'm
assuming that this time wraiths does not
kill him he's able to escape with his
life barely but then goes on to continue
doing what he was doing during the end
of season two and then becomes the black
flash so even though it seems like
they're really messing with the timeline
here with this particular scene I think
that the explanation is is that he got
away
number four barry and nora versus the
reverse flash this is probably my
favorite time that they went back to
just because of the way the reverse
flash reacts to them in all the Easter
eggs that he drops probably more Easter
eggs per seemed we got in any other
episode so one he names off a whole
bunch of female speedsters trying to
guess who Nora is he says Jesse chambers
that's Jesse quick Liddy Lawrence was
Jesse quick smother she went by the name
Liberty Bell and wore this costume that
you see then he names off Danica
Williams who's the flash of the Batman
Beyond timeline so some of them older
speedsters some of them future
speedsters maybe we'll see Danica
Williams Batman Beyond stuff in future
seasons who knows but anytime they name
drop stuff like that they usually find a
way to pay it off down the road the even
bigger info bomb that he drops is Thawne
calls her dawn I believe it is and she
says no my name is Nora and then II
chuckles and says well at least you
still have one essentially meaning that
he's confirming the tornado twins for
later this season meaning that Nora
should have been a twin but the timeline
changed because of something that Nora
did so maybe they fixed the timeline by
the end of the season and we get our
tornado twins dawn and Dawn back and
they pay off that Barry gibberish from
the beginning of season four where he
says
going to need more diapers because then
they would have twins instead of just
having Nora so you can thank the
reverse-flash in the future from that
2049 date where Nora runs to for
probably precipitating a lot of this
stuff happening you start to notice
though some of the weird ways that
reverse-flash thinks about Nora it seems
like he gets some ideas in his head
calls her a clever girl he recognizes
that the plan to use sabotage suit is
crazy advance maybe something that only
he would come up with then suddenly he
looks at Nora and it's almost like he
realizes that he's actually talking to
himself in the future like oh I sensed
that I'm doing this from some other
future timeline so he's kind of laughing
to himself knowing that he's going to
get the better of Barry out like he
knows something that Nora's doing that
Barry doesn't 3 Barry and Nora go back
to the night Barry got his powers they
see the explosion she almost touches
Grodd through the cage don't touch that
and they shot a whole bunch of new
footage with Caitlin and Cisco they even
made a reference to the night that
reverse-flash killed Cisco like they
pair them off they're standing in the
same configuration that they were when
he killed him and he raises his hand up
and then it turns into like this funny
fist bump handshake they even included
some footage of Ronnie - and even
Caitlin in the future recognizing that
they would go back to that night is like
oh yeah they're gonna be seeing Ronnie
so you get to see her be a little sad
about him for a second they enter the
Time Vault and drop a whole bunch more
Easter eggs
they got Morena Baccarin to come back
and record a new voice-over dialogue for
this version of Gideon
she knows who Nora is and says that
she's the fifth recruit of the Legion of
super-heroes I mean he gets cut off but
it's also a reference to the first time
that Barry learned about Gideon and she
almost tells Barry that he's a member of
the Justice League in the future really
awesome foreshadowing moment with a Nora
trying to touch reverse flashes suit
like you can sense that she's fascinated
with him I wasn't expecting as big of a
payoff as we got in the episode but this
was probably enough clues to tell us
that she was involved with him in some
way number two team flash takes down
cicada with the help of Caitlin I
thought it was funny that their little
device I mean it works but it doesn't
work because he's able to recall the
dagger from outer space because he's
gotten so powerful but they do make the
mental note that may be killer frost is
the key to defeating cicada so just keep
that in the back of your mind they won't
come back to that till the second half
of the season in January
number one though they finally pay off
Nora's diary and the person she's
communicating to in the future
never mind I'll go tell him myself so
she's been communicating with
reverse-flash in the year twenty forty
nine and it seems like either she or
someone else has captured him thrown him
in iron Heights prison but even though
they didn't completely explain what's
going on here I think what happened is
is in the future
Nora sensed that he was smart enough to
help her try and save Barry from crisis
on Infinite Earths because that's her
real mission this season to try and find
a way to save Barry from disappearing or
dying in 2024 so she probably went to a
different time period to get reverse
flashes help and he consequently is
probably trying to manipulate her so
that it will change the timeline in a
way that will benefit him to make
another Cisco pun the vibe they're also
going for is Silence of the Lambs with
Clarice Norah talking to reverse-flash
Hannibal Lecter behind the glass quid
pro quo I tell you something you tell me
something so what happened at the end of
Silence of the Lambs Hannibal Lecter
escaped prison so just expect
reverse-flash to break out some time
during the back half of the season let
me know in the comments though what do
you guys think reverse flashes true plan
is and what was your favorite moment
from the episode there was a new
Elseworlds trailer I'll do a breakdown
to that tomorrow morning we're also
supposed to get an Avengers 4 trailer
later this week and a spider-man far
from home trailer so I'll just update
people on the schedules I post videos
that I'll name a winner when I post that
new Elseworlds trailer click here for my
brand new Captain Marvel trailer and
click here for that brand new Elseworlds
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]